this diagram shows a grid measuring four
by six centimeters the aim is to get
from A to B and you can only move
downwards or to the right a single move
is defined as shifting along one side of
a square so it takes you ten moves to
get from A to B that was a clue by the
way that was a clue so let's have a look
at this how many different routes are
possible now just like with this making
triangles question I think the lion's
share of the thinking in this question
is how do I translate this or this into
the right language so I can say oh it
must be this I think that's the hardest
time okay so to think about this
remember the rules are you can only
travel to the down two to the right or
down okay so let's just think of what
might be a part through this grid right
well the simplest path the simplest
paths would be right right right right
no no no no no no right so it would look
like this and six of these this is one
successful path through the grid right
it would be another one how about do a
couple of writes then a couple of down
there's a couple more writes now by this
time right I've hit the edge over here
because I've gone right four times and
then I've got four more to go down does
that make sense so you go along here
what's this one gonna look like it's
gonna go down cross down cross all the
way down I can keep on going this can be
quite a few of them but hopefully by
writing them in this way you sign you
click can what kind of question is this
I have to is it different to do this
versus this is it are these are these
counted as different ways the answer is
yes they're different routes I think
they're different routes now what's the
difference between these two the only
difference is order okay so I'm in
permutations land does that make sense
so I had to think carefully what kind of
question is this
this is the tool for what kind of
question is this it's permutations okay
now also I want you to know what I've
got to do and they gave you this
question this clue in the question right
I have to make exactly ten news yes I
did have to make exactly ten moves right
it's not like you've got some news and
you only choose some of them right
you've got ten routes to do and you've
got to fill every single one right so
this is not just permutations this is 10
P 10 but you have to pick 10 things to
fit into those spots and by the way
that's 10 factorial remember now ah okay
sir working out how many ways to choose
a series of 10 objects to fit into 10
spots this is my first one total wins I
have to begin by saying 10 factorial
right 10 spots 10 things to put in those
spots there are 10 things to put in the
first one 9 things etc ah but of course
you'll like hold on a second if for
instance you took these two guys this
right in this right and switch to if you
like but that's the same because they're
birthrights
I can't tell the difference in any of
these right so I have identical elements
don't I all right so you see these guys
these guys here how many ways can these
turns rearrange themselves and I would
be able to tell how many ways answer 4
factorial so I'm over counted by that
time and then these guys can rearrange
themselves to in 6 factorial ways I've
overcome by that as well there are told
you the lion's share of this question
that thinking is in seeing through this
- what is it really asking right how can
i phrase this question in a way that REM
does it you know helpless at the mercy
of the tools that I have all right so
now maybe you can walk through and do
the rest with me right pop B says how
many ways are there from A to B via C ok
now what this is is breaking one journey
into two pieces right firstly you
have to get from A to C you have to do
that like otherwise you'll miss C and
you won't meet the condition and then
after you're at sea
you've got to get from C to B does that
make sense so I just have to do the
first kind of journey then do the second
hundred okay think about it might be to
get from A to C from A to C how many
turns is it going to take me oh four
turns right to right and two down so
I've got a Fiat four moves into four
spots but there are some repeated there
are two bikes that can swap in a hotel
and there are two down there can swap
and I can't tell
so this is how to do the first leg of
the journey and then you can tell me how
to get from C to B how many steps six
steps but there's an over counting
factor on etc okay but but you need to
do these and you need to do these
otherwise if you don't you put together
you shouldn't get to be case you don't
add them you multiply so the total ways
ah this one by this one whatever that
number happens to be I think it's 19th
so memorize 6 times 15 which is 9 so
seam in here it's just a small book
that's exactly what happened here did
you notice that right within the
question there are smaller versions of
the original question okay Part C Part C
they say okay this top line is
off-limits right they're like no go no
go can't do that right so therefore from
a now how many options do I have
from a there's only one way I can go you
want to get to here let's call this spot
underscore X okay and then you've got to
get from X to B are there any
restrictions on how you get from X to be
nope so therefore Patsey no total ways
are firstly one there's only one way to
get off a
I'm just gonna write one and then I've
got to go from here to here how many
ways from X to B how many our story I
should say how many moves there's nine
factorial - right but yes that's right I
have to do five steps down than all
identical and I do four steps to the
right that are all identical yes yes it
is
but yeah so in some ways coincidentally
okay because these two numbers here come
from the fact that I've got identical
objects not because there's a Miss
factorial and as ones that factorial
they didn't have to be like exactly
matching and identical okay but yes this
happens to be 95 um last one last one so
that was the way the top line now
they're saying
actually you know what top lines okay
let's let's put this guy back but now
it's the second line that's it done okay
now so I can't travel to the right here
I can go through it I'd go through it
but I can't travel on it okay now this
becomes a little bit tricky but not that
much not that much I wrote I'm gonna try
and break this down to size okay so I've
got these points under here that I have
to get to Julia one of them right so I'm
gonna give them names P Q okay now you
can see how many ways are there from a
to P how many ways from a to P it's only
one way right so I've got you from a to
P and then I have to do this journey on
which there are no restrictions right
services this is you think I'm gonna
need more space what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say the total ways I can get from
a to P that's okay but then I've got to
get from paid to be in there's lots and
lots of different ways I can do it is
that make sense so therefore I'm going
to say that's going to be equal to
see here p2b how many steps how many
moons should peter be I think it's eight
right so that's eight factorial on this
is for bit of the same key that are
identical and for the same key that I
did full factorial 4 factorial okay yeah
okay but that's not the only way to get
bit and I'm adding I'm adding because
I'm now thinking about going from
somewhere else okay so I want to trick
you as my launching pad right so I'm
gonna get to Q and then I'm gonna think
well how do I get from Q to be huge to
be well it takes me seven moves to do it
seven factorial right but some of these
moves are identical and I can tell the
difference
there's 4 factorial 3 factorial over cut
it because of the AHS Indies that are
the same to me okay and then I got C and
then over R and then upon s so let's
have a look at this how does the pattern
unfold let's say 6 factorial on yeah
yeah then I've got to go from R which is
this guy 4 factorial 1 factorial and
then lastly I've got to go from s now
think for a second right fee for a
Centon I've got four minutes to go right
but all four of those look identical to
me
so I've accounted by all those ways and
of course because there's only one way
from this too big does that make sense
that's why that last guy is just one so
I have no idea what happens when you add
those all up but those are all the cases
okay these are all the cases I've got a
number actually yeah
yeah yeah you can do some factorizing
here now by the way I'm glad my pitcher
C and D they have the same Arthur C and
D but why is that that's exactly right
both times you simply turn this six by
four thin into a five by four and that's
why it's the same problem see that it's
that's just 5 by 4 and that's exactly
the same way I think about it's just I
had to it was in the middle so who is
not as easy it was not as easy to
eliminate like that that row but it
ended up exactly the same okay and it's
kind of nice that since this is solving
the same problem doing it a very
different way much less efficient this
is this way